but we begin this morning with a
recommendation from a food and drug
administration panel for senior citizens
and other at-risk americans to get a
third shot of the pfizer coronavirus
vaccine the pfizer vaccine is the most
widely used of the three vaccines in the
u.s with more than 219 million shots
administered 98.5 million americans have
gotten two shots of the pfizer vaccine
it was the first to be authorized for
emergency use and was used in the
earliest stages of america's vaccination
program when people over age over the
age of 65 and high risk individuals were
prioritized but the fda is saying the
boosters are not for everybody michael
george is here with more michael good
morning michelle good morning for a lot
of americans this can be tough to follow
so let's break this down the advisory
panel basically was only looking at the
pfizer vaccine and while they say
booster shots are a good idea for
at-risk people there's still not enough
data to show everyone should get one
dr wharton voted no dr fuller voted no
that's no for healthy people under 65
for those older or anyone regardless of
age with a compromised immune system
they should plan to get a third pfizer
shot as early as next week the fda will
review the advisory committee's
recommendations then the cdc steps up
for a final say
all this comes at a time when new cdc
data shows a drop in the effectiveness
of the pfizer vaccine over time at two
weeks to four months it was 91 percent
effective beyond 120 days effectiveness
fell to 77 percent the moderna vaccine
showed no decrease
there has been an uptick in the number
of people getting vaccinated in recent
weeks but the news from government
agencies might bring confusion i think
the lack of clear messaging is certainly
going to confuse people and it's going
to make it harder for some people
to get that third shot if they need it
or maybe even some people
their first shot still the unvaccinated
continue to stretch many hospitals to
the limits making it harder for doctors
and nurses to treat patients with other
conditions that's what's happening in a
leading minnesota hospital there's
enough covet in the icus right now that
makes it challenging
for a patient with simple pneumonia
who's very sick from it or a patient
who's perhaps had a bad heart attack to
find a bed in an expeditious manner as
vaccines rise there are still 70 million
people in this country who have not been
vaccinated get vaccinated take the
vaccine at a poignant ceremony in
washington yesterday was a reminder of
the toll of the coronavirus acres of
flags were flown to commemorate the more
than
670 thousand people in this country who
have died from the virus the
smithsonian's lonnie bunch officiated
the opening ceremony they come from all
backgrounds all faiths from all ethnic
and political categories it reminds me
to make sure that those who are lost are
never forgotten
and right now 2 000 people per day are
still dying from covet an analysis by
the new york times shows new cases are
down a little in recent weeks but it's
still much higher than it was in the
early spring and summer michael thank
you very much